two
here we are baby
it is wednesday today
might be thursday when you're watching
it
but it's the midweek show and we are
here to tear it up off the rails
he takes that five percent
wait
what's that what was the home
do you uh do you not know
oh
it's a uh
friend of the show formerly wait is that
a nutrition drop it very well might be
yeah
very well might be yes
interesting
oh here it is
wait what is this
is this a real thing here
what okay by the way welcome to off the
rails we're getting right into it
today's
today's episode is sponsored by uh
stamps.com thank you thank you
uh
what is this
gold
what's happening
why are people throwing tomatoes at here
what's happening right what is this you
guys
guys what
what did i miss
uh
i believe she's into uh eastern
mysticism and meditation
why are there being why are there
tomatoes being thrown at her you know
why
wait
okay so
as i can best gather
is that
she's live streaming on tick tock 30 000
people watching that's that's pretty
significant pulling numbers yeah
um she seems to be meditating of some
sort and the people are
paying money to throw tomatoes at her
how much should it cost to throw a
tomato do you guys know i believe it's
99 cents let me double check okay so
okay that's a pretty good
that's a pretty good deal
i think uh i might have found my new
song favorite new sound bite
yeah um this is this is good [ __ ] right
here my friends
yeah the good thing is that
i just what so what she's like her i
heard something like she's hari krishna
now or something
uh sure she is
well you say that was skepticism she was
hara krishna this week what's today
today is wednesday
okay nevermind i think
kari krishna's on
tuesdays yeah
jew for jesus is on thursday
joel austin disciple
that's every day let's be honest
right
there's no contradictions there
okay let's watch this one more time
because what the [ __ ]
but she's obviously trolling right like
i don't think she would mind
i don't think she would mind us watching
this she's obviously trolling yeah i
like i think i agree there's no way she
thought this would go over any other way
live streaming her doing this
the tomatoes just
i'm surprised tick-tock even programmed
in the ability to throw tomatoes at
somebody
that's true
yeah i mean they have to know the
context of that the connotation there's
no other use of throwing a tomato
it's just non-stop tomatoes by the way
non-stop tomatoes man
maximum velocity tomato throwing
one two
did she probably she could have made a
thousand bucks for people chucking
tomatoes at her
how about way to make a make a buck
i mean that's kind of her whole career
in one
short one image of just her cleaning
making money people throwing tomatoes at
her yeah
true
oh
this is wild you guys
wait i'm confused is is okay wait is
this all people paying like it says this
girl sent a rose is that yeah the roses
these are all tick-tock stickers i'm
looking for oh so this is all people
paying a dollar
yeah those ones at top yeah where it has
any of the like big emojis yo while i
would way rather throw the flour doesn't
do anything throw a tomato
i think it just kind of sprinkles uh
some petals oh oh okay it's it's weird
how they do it you you pay in coins but
you pay for the coins with actual money
so i'm not sure if it's a dollar for
each one but microtransactions baby
so she's actually cleaning up here she
got flowers she got tomatoes
she got the whole thing is just
wow
a flower is like a couple pennies
is there
oh okay so the tomato is a bigger
investment
i'm guessing i'm not seeing the tomato
on here maybe that was a one time it's
just a few cents people are sending her
yeah she's literally a beggar on the
street corner and people are just
talking flicking pennies at her because
one rose is one coin but you could buy
65 coins for a dollar
yeah
gotcha
wait was that love on the um monitor
i mean was that trisha on the monitor
oh right oh wait no that's love i feel
like she's ascended that was sunday
sunday's chicken chicken nuggets
i feel like she's ascended from that
the nuggie identity she's in
she's the whole tender now she's
remember this
wait what is this love jesus that's
disturbing
there you go i don't like how the legs
jiggle go back to love actually i
actually do like how the legs jiggle
it's disturbing keep jiggling them
how much does it cost to throw a tomato
how many coins
i'm not seeing the tomato everywhere i'm
now i'm googling it because i couldn't
find it in tik tok
yeah this is important for me it's
specially programmed for her for her
account yeah the
account manager added it just for her
for this live stream
i i've i've never seen that on tick tock
i've never seen people chucking tomatoes
dude
this is the best thing
this is this is amazing i mean
look it's non-stop tomatoes
just non-stop
all right i mean she's obviously
trolling why would you live stream
yourself meditating like that if you
wanted to meditate you just do it in the
privacy
that's the whole point of meditation
right is like aloneness oneness i don't
know anything about meditation
certainly some people certainly
streaming live streaming your um
your meditation is
not encouraged in
most traditions she's got a great
vibrato man i'll tell you
anyway
that was exciting
um
just a gentle reminder at the top of the
show that over on teddyfresh.com we have
our black friday sale
running through november
you can get still the color block is on
sale the three panel hoodie is 50 off
spongebob
50 off
all these beautiful hoodies let me
showcase today the paisley petty
i love this hoodie it's so nice
the fabric the material used on it is
beautiful so this is on sale right now
teddyfresh.com
the only time of the year
thank you
also teddy fresh uh looney tunes uh
pop-up is happening on
this saturday is that right
correct
me and ela will not be attending
unfortunately we figured that it's a bad
time to do a fan meetup and i'm very
sorry
i feel horrible i really wanted to be
there it sucks but i hope you guys still
go and have fun
um the address is on our social media to
refresh instagram
all right anyway um here we are
we've got a lot of really really fun
stuff to talk about here today
uh starting with soflo
antonio which is a name we've not heard
and many a moon
a long time
a long time soflo antonio for i guess
there's a lot of new people here who may
not know who soflow is
but man he was one of the og youtube
pranksters who was doing like super
racist like pranks in the hood
he was basically running a bunch of
scams on facebook
he uh did a bunch of fake pranks
stealing content from people and just
like the cringiest dude you could
imagine
um super successful on facebook
obviously
where people like that go to have
extraordinary success oh that's what's
up where was this just follow me on
instagram where was this posted on his
youtube channel the first video he's not
oh [ __ ] look at the channel no
this is a straight up
he premiered it too
look it's a premiere
whoa
no way wait can you get back while i
watch this
he says i know this vid will get a bunch
of hate because i haven't posted in a
very long time but i'll making a full
video explain where i have been
i'll be coming back to youtube don't
worry dude nobody [ __ ] one like
yeah nobody's
nobody's waiting dude
well after this i mean wait until they
see this banger content that he's
posting can one of you guys while i
watch this see if it's on his instagram
or facebook if it got he's not on his
instagram i uh i have his instagram
linked
um in the doc
right after this
uh it could be on tick tock or something
i need to know if this kind of stuff
goes viral oh yeah on tick tock or or um
facebook
anyway here he is this is bella porch
followed me on instagram gone wild
yeah he used to put that in the title of
all his videos was gone wild
so here we go without further ado
yo that's what's up teleports just
follow me on instagram i'ma slide into
dms real quick let's see what's up damn
she just saw us what's up she's typing
she's typing
damn she just stopped typing she's
already playing games with me man ah she
back she back oh what's up girl you know
why is it blurry i know it went down to
like
20 240 p
okay there it is let me go back a little
bit
this we need to follow all the action
carefully games with me man ah she back
she back oh what's up girl you know
what's up so tell me the truth why you
follow me you like me or something
oh [ __ ] i think we need to shoot our
shot real quick we can shoot a shot
let's go let's try to get her on a date
let's see if we can do it
of course we should girl come on i get
you 5 million likes and a tickety top
damn you want wait so soflo offered to
get her 5 million likes on tick tock i
mean isn't she the
tick tock like the third biggest
isn't he saying if he gets 5 million
likes she'll go on a date with him
i don't think so
he says
i guess i don't know it's that's exactly
what it says how how about i get five
million likes on tick tock a date ticket
of course we should girl come on i get
you 5 million likes and a
kitty talk i guess he does say 4 to you
yeah ok how about i get 5 million likes
on a tick tock for you
how about 10 million likes and one
million shares okay so yeah he's trying
to beg people for likes and shares yeah
that is my understanding but the the
message is very poorly
delivered and by the way if she followed
you and she says you're cute i think
you're already in bro i don't think you
need people to like
have you found this on his tick though
kb
i can't find a sig talk i'm looking for
it i also can't find his tick tock yeah
i've seen a bunch of fakes but i will
say this is a trend on tick tock i see a
lot of people i've been seeing people do
this should i post this for my account
and see what happens
just as your own video i'll be like this
is good content so flow if you're not
gonna post it i will
okay what does this you it'll probably
get removed which is ironic because
that's what he used to do with people
right it's content yep i followed i
found it it is on a tick tock it has 1.8
million views no
no
god no no sorry that's a part two part
one has 6.2 million views
that sucks bella has to go on a date
with him now
i hate that this [ __ ] always works he it
always works he's so [ __ ] dumb and
bad and makes the worst content and it
always works and i don't know why
send me a link i sent it tic tac has a
lot for these guys to have a rebirth
they're doing all the same tricks now
five years later right this is not okay
yeah didn't we find out the other
they're all that's what they're all back
the other prank
hold on the [ __ ] phone i gotta read
these comments this is not okay that
well we never actually finished this
let's finish watching just follow me on
instagram i'm just like this
please smash that like button and share
this with all your friends
yo bro i [ __ ] hate this man
stop
so here's the comments
i mean nobody believes this yet yet here
we are
i mean he's just harvesting 12 year olds
i guess i mean who else would
participate in such a nightmare
oh my god i can't tell you this is uh so
here this is part two which has 1.8
million so last week bellapoor's
followed me on instagram
by the way she
not that it needs to be said but she
doesn't follow him wait
i know i know it's crazy it's hard to
believe
yeah
yeah she doesn't follow him
you know she does follow me but
but he he got the likes
she's contractual wait did he i don't
think he got the likes
no oh he said he needs
he needed like 10 million
he's not he's not there bro he needed a
million likes yo that's what's up he's
not he's only halfway there oh not even
halfway okay
well hopefully bella comes through when
he does hit that milly
so last week bellaport's followed me on
instagram so i decided to slide into her
dm see if she would go on a date with
you
by the way pretty ballsy
so last week
followed me on instagram
didn't even follow her back damn
cold-blooded wow
what a pimp i decided to slide into her
dm see if she would go on a date with
you
talk for a little bit she told me i was
cute i knew it was my chance so i went
in for it
that i had to get 10 million likes on a
tick tock video so i decided to give it
a shot but unfortunately it didn't go as
viral as i thought it would
[ __ ] it got six million views
you [ __ ]
for nothing
with 5 000 views and everyone [ __ ]
on him
and i find a video was like [ __ ] 6
million views you [ __ ]
as long as you have no shame you can
make it on tick tock
that's so [ __ ] crazy it's so dumb
it's not even no [ __ ] like clearly he
has no shame you're right but it's so
dumb it's so
a week i decided to tell her the truth
we didn't make it to 10 million likes
but then she responded with
if you get 1 million you can go on a
coffee date which i thought was great
and i know for a fact we can do she's
like if you got 10 i would have i would
have [ __ ] you but
1 million i'll get you some coffee
because we're a family and we're a team
so everyone drop a like and we'll catch
how about you go [ __ ] yourself
and get off the internet and
stop this madness
i hate him
what else are you really feel
here's a video with abe
what is this
wait jeffrey
jeffrey
he's not even in this video
he forgot his signature filter the i
won't lie this is definitely right
so by the way what he used to do is he
would rip people's content
off youtube and put his watermark on it
and post it on facebook so he's like
straight up a criminal it would look
like this well let's not forget the last
time we talked about soflo was talking
about his
selling of fake um masks for kovid at
the start of the pantemic
yeah
right i forgot he was selling fake masks
dude when masks were all sold out
yeah he oh yeah we're like he's gonna
get arrested but i yeah he was
advertising them as n95 masks uh
when when there was like a total
shortage of them like basically shortly
after that or right around there where
he [ __ ] off to south korea where he
apparently still is and i this is not a
joke think that he is
he's a wanted man he's probably on the
run from the fbi yeah right he had this
massive drop shipping fraud i or i don't
think he ever even shipped it people out
it was just straightforward
thunder labs is what it was called
thunder labs oh is that website still up
um there was like a ton of facebook
reviews just i was like i never got my
mask this is fake
does south korea have extradition laws
with you uh
treaties i wonder with the us or they
just uh almost certainly do i mean
they're close allies so yeah there's
probably better places to hide so maybe
he's uh not wanted he's flying under
maybe he's planning an escape to north
korea he'll be off the grid there well
certainly certainly
kim jong-un and him will be good friends
they're gonna making tick-tocks together
uh thunder labs has not posted on their
social media since january of 2020 so it
appears that's a shame it has
disappeared yeah he's actually a
straight-up criminal well
being unfunny is not even the worst
thing he's done it's close though
it's close
smart not to put himself in this video
oh
my
god go ahead i have a
play the no such thing as a coincidence
music right now
get it going zach
no [ __ ] you ready uh-oh
thunder labs website right
let me scroll down
network
who have they worked with
relativity media
that can't be real though they've been
bankrupt since before he existed i don't
know cav cav
bought accounts i think he has some
explaining to do who
do you think are behind those bot
accounts allegedly i mean sofia does
have the know-how to be buying almost
certainly
fashion nova style hall there's no such
thing as a coincidence
i just open their website and scrolled
down and that just caught my eye that's
pretty amazing
there is no such thing as a coincidence
really i mean cathcav and soflow would
get on great absolutely
our facebook pages were the first to hit
1 billion views
and did over 240 mil i was i was
actually reading that oh
um
and we did over 240 million views in a
single day that's one percent of all
worldwide viewership on facebook at the
time okay what are you doing for me now
what do they say they do due to high
demand we only have the bandwidth work
with a set number of clients at any
given time
they're saying that they're like
some sort of
media growth company but remember scroll
down
when we looked at this they were it was
a online shop before so somehow thunder
labs has changed from
thunder labs manages content that
averages over a billion views per month
thunder labs is home to some of the most
powerful consumer video
video brands
we are an engagement powerhouse
oh yeah actualized by our close-knit
ties to the influencers this is
this is a nightmare you guys
let's dig into his tik-tok more because
you know on tick tock he has 9 million
followers
um
i hate that here's one with him in it
this has 9 million views
the one to the right of that
shows that he's still the comedian he's
always been still has that class a humor
i'll play that after this
billion is that for real check out this
magic trick
um
dude can you [ __ ] not
what
wait do you think that's copyrighted
music
yes okay
the among us trap remix
the among us trap remakes
dude what the [ __ ] bro
he's just typing in
this is the worst thing
i don't even know what that was but i
hate it i'm out you said there's some
sofa humor here
the girl in the green yep
okay
all you gotta do is apply some force
i'll show you what's up check it out
now now there there's no reason
that anybody anywhere of any age should
be watching and enjoying this content
period that's that's just a problem with
humanity
like i'm sorry but
this is not okay
i'm in pain
okay that one was rough
it's time to stop
here look he was kind of a
heavy just stealing content i mean on
tick tock you could just do duets but
he was the first one he's an innovator
yeah so here is a ticked well i'm
curious what's happening here because
he's oh okay so he's still still in
content this is a tick tock from this
guy my whatever
it shows the tag it's not so flow he
just ripped it and re-uploaded it that's
amazing
no relevance to him
or his page
just straight up ripped it off that's
the soflo uh classic right there
wow man wow man
that's a so flawless end
wow
uh this again it says my
kale d forgotten it's his
tick tock account
and he's just downloaded it
and uploaded it to
his tick tock
he has nothing to add
what
yeah he didn't add anything he just
uploaded their video
that's crazy man
i can't [ __ ] believe this guy
i hate him he's he's a piece of [ __ ]
what'd you send me i'm getting all
worked up i gotta chill
this is a duet that he legit just he's
in this one though at least but he
copies the joke of the guy who do edit
it
okay whatever
just upload someone else's wait
i'm starting to
i'm starting to register something kind
of crazy here
okay that that other account that you
were just saying he stole it from
i mean
scroll further back on soflo's page
i think he might have bought this tick
tock page
because i noticed earlier
in the comments when you pulled it up
people were like where's michael what
happened to michael or whatever and then
i think he bought it and changed the
name yeah
oh
because how else could he get 9 million
that makes way more sense right than him
somehow acquiring people are saying
where's michael where's michael yeah
when one of the videos you pulled up
there was multiple comments about
michael and then
just now when you pulled that up and it
that tag on that video said michael i
was like wait that that isn't that who
people were asking about and yeah it
scrolled down on his page it's like it's
the same it's some other dude's tick
tock account
oh he he commented on this by the way
and no means making fun of her having a
fake eye okay thanks bro thanks for
clarifying welcome woke can we have
michael back
there was a comment on that one wait
okay we need michael who is michael
where did he bury the body
i think he took michael out bro
i'm trying to find more where's michael
comments
here where is it
i don't know i i've seen like three or
four at this point though but if you
just scroll way down on the account it's
weird you'll know that my
map no
where's michael guys
michael is missing
so that bella tick tock is actually his
his first tick tock
yeah seemingly so
whoa what the [ __ ]
although that one slapped so maybe he
knows what he that one was off the rails
well because this account
was already had a ton of followers dude
9 million dude don't under don't
let's see what this is this is the one
he posted after he uh
his first original one i mean yeah he's
still just ripping it off
this is just a rip of someone's tick
tock
i don't know what's happening but i hate
it
i'm out
thank you may you be arrested and sent
to the google you know what i hope soflo
sent to um
where's that prison where they like make
you get naked and
torture you
uh abu ghraib is that what you're
talking about
vladimir putin guantanamo bay guantanamo
bay okay i hope i hope they send them to
guantanamo bay for this gotcha
vladimir putin okay we've spent like
that's enough about soul flow that is
enough
um we watch that we've got um
guys uh this is pretty interesting
youtube is removing dislikes
sorted
let's see uh to
reduce targeted dislike attacks
and their impact on creators
you'll no longer see a public dislike
count on youtube starting today the
dislike button is staying
hold on let's read let's hear it hey
folks you may have seen a while back
that youtube announced
that youtube announced it was
experimenting with well take note of
that let's give a fun farewell to the
dislike
exactly just by everyone's disliking
making dislike counts private you know
what happened they made this creator
studio account and they've got a
shitload of dislikes and they're like we
don't like that this kind of sucks this
sucks she's only the creator of the
video why am i if you're like me you
were surprised by that i mean
in i've always thought seeing the number
of dislikes on a video helps us know as
viewers if it's a good video or not if
it's a helpful tutorial or not or if
what a creator is is saying in their
video is generally agreed with
well what do you make about this bro 8.2
000 districts
what do we think i mean
i feel like if you have a sense of humor
at all you you have to dislike this yeah
you have to yeah so whether or not you
you're happy with this change
that's the warning
but unfortunately research teams that
youtube have found there's this whole
other use for disliking a video that you
don't need
to figure that out
people use a dislike a button to tell
people to [ __ ] off
or to troll we had a 10 year long
research team we employed 500
researchers from over the world in the
world and invested a billion dollars
and we've concluded
that some people use the dislike button
to troll
what is trolling
experienced as a creator and you may not
have either
apparently groups of viewers are
targeting a video dislike button to
drive up the count turning it into
something like a a game with a visible
score
and that who would do that
on the internet
it's awesome that they're like talking
about they just discovered and it's
usually just because they don't like the
creator or what they stand for
that's a big problem when half of
youtube's mission is to give everyone a
voice
so earlier and what about the voice of
people that hate your guts and want to
dislike you
they don't get a voice anymore
2021 youtube experimented with making
the public dislike count private to see
if it would help reduce these
coordinated dislike attacks across the
platform it won't and after analysis
they did see a reduction so the update
from youtube is that the dislike button
is staying but the dislike counts will
now be private now only you can still
yeah i know i thought that was funny
this just means more hate comments right
and that you i mean that's an
interesting theory no i mean like yeah
you'll look people at the top comments
to see how everybody else feels right
people are going to want to express
their frustration or anger or
dissatisfaction
they can still do it there'll be a
comment at the top and we'll say this is
you just like use me as a dislike button
that's going to be on every video on
every video murder
the thing is at least the creators are
gonna be able to control that i think
that's what they yeah you can remove
that i guess it's true and this is all
leading back to tick tock they're just
same thing with the shorts just to keep
up with tick-tock
what does this do with tick-tock likes
dislikes because the dislikes aren't on
tick-tock
right it's just hearts yeah
it's like videos and that action will be
used to tune your own recommendations
but you won't be able to see the display
and after analysis they did see a
reduction so the update from youtube is
that the dislike button is staying but
the dislike counts will now be private
you can still dislike videos and that
action will be used to tune your own
recommendations but what
the dislike button tunes recommendations
i had
that is
huge
that is huge
i had that is [ __ ] huge that is huge
thing that they just disclosed yeah
because if i dislike someone's like
apology video i don't want to
miss the rest of it yeah never see their
videos again right or if you like it
dislike an episode of the podcast you
dislike it and then they're like oh he
doesn't ever want to see their videos
again
well i was under the impression and this
is from talking to people at youtube too
is that the dislike like have no effect
on anything at all
but this [ __ ] is telling me here
today
that that affects
your discovery that is insane
people i think people need to know that
because they throw the dislike button
around like nothing doesn't mean you
never want to see their videos again
am i alone and feel like i've always
known that
i agree yeah i feel like
i've known that too
well
uh oh i've talked to people i i i think
there's been like a rumor people have i
think people are going to study that
right but youtube's never confirmed
itself i always figured it was like a
myth that the
that the more engagement does and i've
talked to youtube i mean i've i've
literally talked with them and they say
that it does nothing
they're lying to you bro
sketch who's on the phone but i don't
think they'll like the like doesn't do
anything it doesn't increase engagement
um it doesn't everything you say is us
now i i don't know if i believe you
ethan
it doesn't bro it doesn't private
you can still dislike videos and that
action will be used to tune your own
recommendations i cannot believe what
i'm hearing right now this is
shocking
but you won't be able to see the dislike
count
only the creator can find it on the back
end also like generally i don't dislike
videos because i feel like a douche
doing it
so i'm not gonna go like dislike
someone's video
because i don't want to see it anymore i
mean you're already watching the video i
don't get it
huh now a few common questions we saw
from the initial experiment
first without a public dislike count how
can viewers tell if a video is worth
watching again i kind of have this
question too but it turns out that while
viewers might use the dislike count to
give them a sense of a video's worth
when the teams looked at the data across
millions of viewers and videos in the
experiment they didn't see a noticeable
difference in viewership regardless of
whether they could see the dislike count
or not in other words it didn't really
matter i mean i would say when i'm
looking for like a tutorial that's the
only time where it matters
but
right
any other time the time that it matters
though yeah it definitely matters if
you're like looking for a premiere or
after effects thing and you see it as 80
dislike you're like okay
yeah or making fun of keem exactly you
know this just occurred to me keemstar
complains that nobody sees his the
videos on his
under recommendations like yeah
everybody just like your videos
obviously that's why [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
or if a video had a lot of dislikes
everybody liked this video apparently
you got to start saying it i know you
don't like to but you got to start
saying i've never said it my whole
career my whole career
i have never instructed anybody to like
my videos smash that like button
we'll just use the soundbite of your dad
each of us all right guys well
apparently it's important smash that
like button because otherwise youtube i
don't ever show you my videos what the
[ __ ] turn all notifications on
and and if you hit the dislike button
you're never going to see my videos
again
stupid [ __ ]
so don't do it even if you disagree with
me
it's the worst thing you could ever do
to me is dislike my video
or not they still watched next common
question if creators can still see the
dislike count on the back end how's that
any different
they can see it if they look for it
inside studio analytics under the
engagement tab but overall it's much
less likely to cause stress and
embarrassment if the count isn't visible
to the public are you embarrassed
how [ __ ] embarrassed are you right
now i'm pathetic [ __ ] i hate the way
this guy's explaining this i hate that
dislikes actually
affect recommendation
[ __ ] one question is this because
youtube rewind got lots of dislikes
no yes it is [ __ ] you brought it up i
wasn't even wondering that nobody was
wondering you brought that [ __ ] up susan
was pissed for tonight
it's all from fortnite bro
they're still mad they're still mad all
these years on golly there are some
teams internally who have learned the
hard way what it feels like to get a lot
he's saying it is now this again is
about protecting all of these like i
just said it's about they got butthurt
about the dislike
although there are some teams internally
who have learned the hard way what it
feels like to get lots of dislikes now
this again is about protecting all
creators and making sure they have a
chance to succeed and feel
safe in doing so all right so that's the
update i hope it doesn't cause too much
frustration honestly i think you're
going to get used to it pretty quickly
and keep in mind other platforms don't
even have a dislike button well shut up
you want to be like all other platform
now you pick me ass platform
so
consider that thank you and i hope
you're welcome so my my take on this was
that i don't really care that they're
removing the dislike button it doesn't
bother me until now i just real this is
very upsetting me that the like buttons
actually affect recommendations this is
upsetting me a lot you guys
it doesn't really make sense for it to
affect
recommendation because people do it
emotionally it doesn't mean i want to
see more or less you know what i'm
saying it's a horrible metric to use
can i report this video
report
harmful indeed uh promotes terrorism
is that is that an option yeah promotes
terrorism
animals die
um
this is on my account you just
terrorized
all right is my mind with the revelation
that like dislike effects
recommendation
i disliked the video and i hope you
always remember that
remember that even after it's disabled
shame on you
just because you got butt hurt that
rewind got blasted
with dislikes doesn't mean you have to
turn it off for everyone
that's it
i think it's great send they'll read
that for sure yep
well put eloquently put
what a douche
i thought he was actually quite a good
presenter in the video
outside of like the content of what he
was saying
he felt like he was much more natural
than these are usually
so kudos to him if you're watching i'm
not i'm not co-signing what you're
saying
this is my opinion
nobody asked in this case for your
opinion okay putting it forward if i
want your opinion i'll ask i'll ask you
sure this i'll ask for a dislike or i'm
sure i would like to be glad to hear
from me okay you put a lot of work in
you know what bro here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna put a like dislike
button on your [ __ ] desk i want to
hear from you i'll come do a digital
like button and then you can speak that
logistically sounds
very difficult i'm gonna i'm disliking
you right now
i don't care dislike [ __ ] disabled
just
remove recommendations from dan
just like to disable
ah i don't know what do you guys think
about the removing of dislikes
hey b you seem to have an opinion
i don't want to upset the youtube guys i
think it's great
i'm not up there what a [ __ ] push why
do you think it's great i mean i again
i'm neutral i think it's fine i don't
know
thank you dan that share really changed
you no i think what it is is
i
they got to do something because
recently tick tock beat youtube and
watch time and total watch time so they
got to do something you think it's the
like dislike button how the [ __ ] was
that
well they're trying everything i had
someone from youtube i have a small
channel reach out to me and want to do a
phone call asking what they could do to
improve shorts so they're really taking
initiative i've never seen them do that
on youtube
like this and it's because of tick tock
and maybe they just associate tic toc
with a better time because there's no
dislikes doesn't mean comments but you
could delete them i don't think that's
why i think tick tock is just insane i
think it's just insanely popular it's
just people like scrolling that [ __ ] the
baby has a point but i think they're
just trying everything yeah exactly it's
motivating them to to finally try and
innovate a little bit they i mean yeah
youtube's been
resting on their laurels a little bit
well maybe they should start promoting
my videos more and paying me more yeah
well that's one option
like how about that they also just
announced there's a huge amount of
features they're basically just lifting
wholesale from twitch for live streaming
that's coming to youtube soon so they're
not bringing to us because we don't play
video games exactly that's why youtube's
in the [ __ ]
we can just
buy and say we're gaming and have those
features turned on probably i need to
write my guy
write your guy
[ __ ] i'm going to write him right now no
not right now
call susan just call susan just let her
know
yeah no because i'll forget hold on
gordon
wait not gordon
um don't say his name let's let's
include this but we have to go to break
so throw it to break and you can uh call
your
person who is not named gordon
time to take a short break
the season of giving is finally here and
so is the holiday rush so if you're
selling anything online you don't have
to face the holiday hustle alone
stamps.com takes all the hustle and
guesswork out of holiday shipping and
saves you money easily compare prices
and delivery dates across major carriers
and get huge discounts up to 40 off usps
and 76 off ups rates
are you serious
whether you whether your sales come from
amazon etsy shopify or ebay stamps.com
streamlines
your shipping and keeps you on your
customers nice list
yeah so
like um your girlfriend uses stamps.com
right dan she does she runs her own
online business and she uses stamps.com
exclusively for all of her shipping and
it is
extremely uh straightforward and easy
and she gets good rates she has a little
a little printer
next to her computer and uh and a scale
stitch printer yeah exactly and you know
oh that's sick so you can weigh it and
print the postage yourself right there
boom and so just rapid fire you know do
like 30 packages and
send it off to the post office and
that's it
yeah that's that's got to be honestly a
a game changer for
for something like that i mean
the savings alone is huge but being able
to just do all that yourself so easily
yeah the time the time you save uh for
over 20 years stamps.com has helped a
million over a million businesses save
time and money with shipping guys
they give you exclusive discounts with
usps ups and dhl probably because they
just do this crazy bulk
it integrates with all your sales
channels across the top marketplaces and
automatically imports shipping info for
each order just print print the label
stick it on and schedule a pickup or
drop off no need to rush around in
holiday traffic with stamps.com built-in
tracking tool and delivery notification
you can avoid these dreaded where's my
back is message from stressed out
customers
and if you ever have a question
stamps.com award award-winning us-based
shipping support team is ready to help
so guys deliver more smiles this holiday
and start shipping and saving with
stamps.com today there's no risk and
with my promo code h3 you get a special
offer that includes a week trial plus
free shipping credits and a digital
shipping scale no long-term commitments
or contracts you'll be up and running in
minutes go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in h3 that's stamps.com promo
code h3stamps.com
easy e-commerce shipping for less
a lot less
youtube
yeah so you guys know about garyvee um
i'm not a fan of gary vee
i have to say i know a lot of people
like him
he just seems like a pseudo
guru a b and love love him he's the guy
who famously said this we did actually
well here this is garyvee
my family once a day genuinely sit there
for five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face so i need to
imagine a family oh this is a duet
it was a stitch because he deleted his
original video you guys couldn't find
the original oh
oh
well well i wrote that on the dock
interesting because i found a lot of
weird re-uploads like this too but what
i said
was let's find the original and you were
like i found in two seconds on tick tock
i actually had everybody called me a
[ __ ] boomer i have the sound bite if
you want to play that i i have the video
just like it's 12 minutes long except to
find a time stamp if play the sound bite
uh you just need to hear it once a day
genuinely sit there for five minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face
well we just heard that awesome that's
exactly what we just heard there's more
isn't there
that's the that's the crux of it let's
be real yeah
anyway we had love go home and do it we
said love let's see well he said that's
my secret to happiness right that second
part is important okay he said that's my
secret to happiness i genuinely sit down
every day and imagine my whole family
being murdered and it makes me feel
happy because i appreciate them more
that's his theory right i says any guy
who's telling me to go home and imagine
my precious two-year-old being shot in
the [ __ ] face every day and died is
not my friend is not a good person i
hate this man this is bad advice love
you went home and you took his advice
how did how was your mental state after
that week
it's still not good
never recovered
no but genuinely we did an experiment
where love volunteered to do that and it
was very unpleasant for you i mean yeah
it's not a good idea i mean i understand
the principle
like imagine something if you were in a
worse position or something but your
family murdered i think it's a bit far
it's a little extreme yes you can say
that every day and look how he says it
was so much gusto it's almost like he
likes imagining it watch this do you
love the most of the world nice also
with the like inspiring music it's like
dude get a grip
family once a day genuinely sit there
for five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face
yeah he's psychotic i don't like him
and that's it nobody will convince me
that he's cool well he put out um
oh wait we have another moment we
uncovered sorry before we get to the
story
is that
cam
shared this with us
this is new never before
seen
gary v
dirt
this is compelling [ __ ] cameron how did
you find this
yeah come over you gotta explain this
because this is good [ __ ] he said he's
been sitting on this for years yeah give
me the lore on this clip because this is
this is fantastic stuff
uh yeah so my buddy my buddy at my old
uh office really liked garyvee and he
was watching that podcast on his own
accord and he just said hey check this
out
what the [ __ ] dude all right well here
it is thank you cam all right guys so so
here's here there that's his dad this is
his dad okay
now that's a big old open lip kiss
there's might have been some tongue
involved there dad i asked you to move
yeah you can what i sold right yeah yeah
and that's uh
yeah right
listen
all right let's go in wait now if you
don't believe me let's go
my dad i asked you to let's go slowly
framework
right some people kiss their parents on
the on the lips i mean that's not the
craziest thing but
tom brady tom brady for example
here we go guys
now
there's a play-by-play
you can see the lips open
look at that maybe he's feeding him
he's kind of like a baby bird he's
spitting in his mouth aggressive [ __ ]
kiss dude that's pa i don't kiss hilo
like that damn it's like a i mean that's
an x-rated kiss dude
yeah there was some tongue exchange yeah
he loves his dad what could you say he
loves his dad oh yeah he does
i mean here there's some stills that are
really good too
so this is by the way yeah
they've got the wine they've got the
cheese they're having a romantic moment
totally and you know well listen he he
lips are open guys he's spent the last
several years imagining this guy getting
shot violently point-blank in the face
so he's gotta
hold on he's gotta hold on to that yeah
you're alive
look at that that's open lit bye and
then if you go down
this is the pucker right i mean look at
that that's all there
my dude
so that's our boy garyvee
dude that's sexual it was just a mystery
sexual
well you know there's like it's not just
a peck it's there's passion there
there's an exchange of of saliva for
sure neither of them look surprised it
was definitely their two heads when they
come together it forms a [ __ ] heart
like it it's
it could have been so like it could have
been an accident but
that ain't no [ __ ] accident
look at he loves his father i get that
but maybe a little too much
all right let's go ahead it's just a
full sentence
anyway this is all goofs and stuff but
seriously if you guys want to watch it's
on episode 11 gary's dad joins the show
at seven minutes and 30 seconds guys uh
we need an explanation
yeah
i got a question for gary what the [ __ ]
is this askgaryvee yeah i sold it right
yeah yeah and that's uh yeah
all right
all right let's
daddy makeout day
anyway just jokes but he put out the nft
as all scammers and
cons have been doing lately you know
and uh people are buying this [ __ ] of
course because they love gary vee
but you guys got to see some of the nfts
he's putting out here
i mean
this is just
this is just upsetting okay
this worm glow a worm
sold
for it said here on the last page
thirty four thousand
dollars
like i'm sorry but this is just [ __ ]
so i just hate it it's just nonsense
it's so
stupid it's nonsense
this will not be worth anything ever
people are being scammed
what are you guys
you guys are fans of his am i crazy
i think that's the intention is showing
that it could be something so shitty in
the thank you what the [ __ ] is that yeah
go ahead um
the value yeah
i can't think looking at my own face
don't look at your face talk to me talk
to ethan
yeah you could have you could have [ __ ]
and sell it the values and the ownership
and it's coming from garyvee the nft
dude who kisses his pups i'm so
distracted
why you got to look at yourself bro just
talk to me
i'm talking to you
bro i can i can draw this on a napkin
nobody's going to pay me 20 000 for it i
mean uh isn't that literally what he did
you want to put that to the theory
yeah
yes
i'll draw a dumb [ __ ] worm and i'm
sorry what's the what is this here
what is it's a dumb [ __ ] worm like
bro you're gonna put a little more
thought into your [ __ ] yeah but what's
your complaint because if he knows he
can make money why wouldn't he do it
thank you it's dumb but he can make
money off it so he does it
just because you can't do something you
should do it yeah if you're shameless
enough sure okay so you admit if you do
your drawing i can put that off up on
openc and sell it probably
put it up on ethan's feet what did you
say
brilliant barracuda
i don't know i find the whole thing a
little disingenuous though because it's
not that's not what he sells he goes on
and on about how nfts are changing the
world that this is important that people
need to own this art you know he doesn't
sell like oh
he's not saying that he's saying there's
opportunity i agree
i agree with that it's an investment i
believe in nfts separately but uh
someone like him promoting it maybe it's
a bit
but that's all that's immediately and
predictably i might add what it is
turning into i mean mcdonald's is
selling an nft of the [ __ ] mcrib now
like 80 000 idealistic dream of it you
know somehow supporting small artists
and allowing them to make money it was
that's that's gone that's completely
[ __ ] gone 80 000 for this dan how do
we know you're not an nft you look like
an nft right now
um
we could sell that yeah i'd buy there
would you pay 80 000 for it you could
pay me yeah i'll pay you you can give me
80 000 you can sit in this chair no it's
your it's yours one day you know i don't
know permanently
oh [ __ ] yeah
80 grand well i'm following garyvee's
plan if i get up to 80k up oh fantastic
never mind the fact that you just buy
your own i mean this is one that sold
for
20 eth
do you know how much that is
that's [ __ ]
70 000 i will also add i am highly
skeptical of those sales
well you can look at the look at the
block jane
yeah and i can see all of joshua 24's
transactions no but the the truth is
people who have this much etherium to
waste on gary vee [ __ ] are usually
scammers they're dudes who own online
crypto casinos who have so much ethereum
and bitcoin they don't know what to do
with it and they think it's like a good
store of value or a good way to hide
their money
um
and this is the people that are paying
gary vee are like there's honestly a lot
of criminals buying this [ __ ] because no
[ __ ] buddy is gonna go spend 20 eth
on this that isn't just drowning in it
from having an illegal casino i just
don't believe that any sane person any
otherwise normal person who's looking to
invest
is buying any of this dog [ __ ] this is
so [ __ ] dumb and i and i i just don't
care what you think you don't want an
authentic anaconda
like in the real world
i don't care who drew it
nobody is buying this nobody
nobody
compared to
normal art like
like the normal art world is kind of
weird too
sure i mean yeah you want to talk about
like this complaint
listen great point love
it's not a i mean i would complain about
like people selling art pieces for 100
million dollars too and the same thing
applies it's not normal people buying it
it's like weird [ __ ] sketchy
underworld [ __ ] to dodge taxes right
there's cheaper ones too
there's nothing so yeah and there are
anything over a million dollars
but bro at least that that stuff has
prestige it has prominence it's famous
historical importance this is garyvee
doodling on a napkin bro it's just like
merch
merch that costs a hundred grand yeah
well everything doesn't cost time i bet
he didn't sell it for a hundred grand
like originally but don't you think he
sold it for let's see it's all on here
right
don't you think it's kind of like
spitting in your [ __ ] face to create
merch this dumb
i mean maybe if the sea lion wasn't
swaggy but the fact that he's swaggy
hmm that could add something to you this
one has never been sold actually uh it
was listed
this is just a random one that i clicked
on and it looks like it was listed
at just under four grand
yeah nice merch bro
that's some that's a big flip on some
merch
i hate it
i just i hate it
because he he gets all of his audience
hyped up on this idea that nft is like
this amazing once in a lifetime
opportunity and he sells them fool's
gold literally fool's gold at [ __ ]
ten thousand dollars a piece
nah i'm not in i'm out
look at this [ __ ]
he couldn't even be [ __ ] to take a
better photo of himself
looks like he's on a football field or
something
idiot yeah he likes the jets he wants to
buy the jets
dude
i just i don't know what to tell you
guys this is not okay that's what this
all is this is fundraising for him
buying a football team
you get a doodle that he made on a
napkin
actually you don't even get that you get
a digital certificate
uh
buy one of the shittiest teams in
football
you know i'd be surprised if he even
made these
himself
like
there's no way i took the time to sit
down and do all these well okay look at
this one has some text look january 21st
your poor relationship with time is your
biggest vulnerability
gary vee
uh that's wise
he should make one that says imagine the
person you love the most and then
make believe that you shoot
them figure with just like blood
violently gushing out yeah now there's
an nft
there's 86 pages of these yeah there's
no way he's creating all these epic
1023 results
they're not even like
actually even like unique i could have
made these they're so it takes like five
seconds to draw this [ __ ] yeah perhaps
you know i kind of agree with this
these are all like pretty ugly but i
just just
generalizedly
what's called generous general putting
everything
yeah yeah like putting everything under
one umbrella is
not very genuine i think what am i doing
there's some cool stuff
there's my point
not that he's made you're saying that
he's made or right
right
he he's not a good example he's my point
okay
there are some great digital artist okay
right
you know
he's not one of them
i agree
i think that's clear yeah well isn't art
in the eye of the beholder
nobody's beholding no dude it's
literally defined by how much ethereum
it sells for these days
you also get access to a three-year
subscription to something called uh
v friends which is like a community
about nfts oh [ __ ] where you get the hot
tips on what nfts to buy and once you
know it he tells you to buy his
it's a great investment there's a
hundred pages of this [ __ ] jesus
overload
what do you think of this nft
i would buy that can you buy this one
now that's a deal let's commemorate this
beautiful moment
oh here he is talking about it this is
interesting
dude i feel like his stands are going to
be pissed a lot of people like him but i
just think he's a douche i'm so sorry
pulled this clip of him he's talking
with this guy and he goes uh who do you
think works harder and he goes oh i work
harder definitely there's no [ __ ] way
you work hard on me i just know that can
you try to find that maybe
here he is creating one guys
the master at work no way
we should have to pay to see this
seriously i mean every frame of this
video is potentially worth at least ten
thousand dollars true this is 30 seconds
long you're looking at like how much
free content
i'm basically a millionaire just
watching this
a mental millionaire
i'm sorry but you should be embarrassed
to sell that you should be
well like love said shameless
shameless is not a good quality for uh
in my opinion not someone to idolize
anyways shame is good we need shame we
need more [ __ ] more
i agree
i think maybe you sent the video you
were asking about
shame
oh wait there's a video of him creating
each one does that what i saw
oh that's [ __ ] interesting here this
could be some interesting content
wait hold on let's click the uh
this legendary glowing worm
oh my god this is the worm
this is the worst one he's creating it
holy [ __ ] it's the way i drew inside the
lines
dude this is amazing
whoa
it's incredible to see the art
just you know a master at
work right like and watch that again
just the the brush strokes
like i said he stays in the lines yeah
staying on the lines is super high level
[ __ ] i mean
usually people could
beyond like
third or blame maybe first grade even
right
so that excludes like you know five
percent of the population
how much is it worth right now this one
is uh currently s five percent less sold
for
so love just said two thousand dollars
was what it was originally uh minted for
that's so much though that's the
starting point
no no no but it
the mint doesn't mean it was sold does
it
mint was the
uh the value that
he sold it for right okay so he sold it
for
2400
and then some [ __ ] bought it four
months later for 41 000
and then another [ __ ] bought it for
hence
his points proven
what point is that that you can that you
can fleece your audience we all know
that no his audience member made a great
amount of money well
but you're making a little bit of an
assumption there yo if the if the
assumption is that you can fleece your
audience and shove whatever dumb [ __ ]
get-rich [ __ ] down their throat that you
can then that's great he proved his
point you know by the same um by the
same logic then you know
i can just promote whatever i want just
as evidence that i can make money doing
anything
right no i kind of agree with it i i
think it's unfortunate that we're
talking about or well we're talking
about this because it's fun but if we
were talking about something else
i would say what i said before but this
is kind of garbage honestly
so ugly look at his face he knows he's
ripping you off look at that he can't
even muster a genuine smile
this one on the right is really now this
one is actually could be worth something
definitely be friends with benefits
and what's interesting about this one is
not only do you get him making out with
his dad
but you also get the worm
the rabbit the barracuda and the cool
rabbit with the bling chain so that's
got to be worth at least a million
[ __ ] yeah
you know what i love i'll concede
i'll concede for you that that that
concept of nft is cool and it's good
but it's being misused by a lot of
people and i think okay then we're
completely on the same page yeah yeah
yeah
that the concept's good and it's cool
and there are a lot of great digital
artists that use it in a way that
benefits them and it's awesome
okay
i want to see him create some other sick
art um
let's see the shoes
let's see
[ __ ] this is so epic that we get to
watch him create it
yo
this is insane the master
the master at work
whoa look you're right he stays in the
line dan yeah he's really good
i like the style to just color the feet
you know and not the legs you probably
spent at least like 30 seconds it's an
interesting use of negative space
honestly it's a
it's a it's a it's a masterpiece
here he is guys
he knows
he knows
this guy [ __ ] knows what he's doing
um
how much was that one for
defeat
110 000 so you know no big deal
110 000
it seems reasonable
what are you asking love how much stuff
sells per day how do i figure that out
no i linked a page where you can see all
the activity oh great that's awesome
yeah so here we can see all the activity
on his uh v friends collection
let's see 5 000 owners trade volume
thousand thirty thousand ethereum holy
[ __ ]
no thirty thousand dollars no that's
thirty thousand ethereum bro oh oh
that's the total volume trade i just
yeah i see what's thirty thousand
ethereum in usd right now
uh-huh
quite a bit 138 million
and so
if he's
if he's getting a commission on all
those which he probably has on right
love
usually five percent yeah
wow
man
wow man
see so he doesn't have to stay in the
lines
he's not worried about it five percent
difference is astronomical
yeah so here you can see somebody i
agree there are a lot of people doing
shady [ __ ] nfts i'm just saying that i
guarantee you there's a video out there
which i'm looking for where he is
self-aware and explaining it to his
audience that it's that easy to sell
something nft space yeah if you're a
[ __ ] self-help guru that people
listen to everything your you think that
some [ __ ] can just draw a shitty
stick figure worm and sell it yeah what
is the message there
it's because he's pitching this as a way
for people to make money to invest in
his dumb ass art he's the only one
making money here dude
and he gets five percent commission on
all this [ __ ]
five percent
five percent
let's see just today oh my god this is
all just today 21 hours ago 38 000 20
hours ago 36 000 19 hours ago 28 000 9
hours ago 60 000 8 hours ago 36 000 7
hours ago 60 000 an hour ago seventy
thousand twenty six minutes ago thirty
two thousand holy [ __ ] bro so he's the
one that takes that five percent
oh yeah
and five percent ain't what it used to
be he takes that five percent
wow that's what you were talking about
but anyway you're obviously you're
entitled to your opinion here baby i
know you like the guy i'm not trying to
beef with you here that's all good
peace
but this [ __ ] makes nfts look dumb as
hell
i mean
i'm sorry it just does
like you know how i know it's dumb if he
did an auction
if garyvee did an auction
and he put this up he came he said yo i
have this art collection i want to
present it
people would not pay 27 000 for this
real the physical real copy it wouldn't
happen would not happen
so why is it that people
want to own a jpeg all of a sudden
not a jpeg
a digital signature right okay you know
what i'm just yeah a jpeg but that's the
thing is you don't even own the art
that's the beauty of it
right
right
so it's just the whole
market literally makes no sense
you can't tell me that even in the most
optimistic outlook of nft that owning a
digital signature
is better than owning the original art
which i guarantee you would be worth
less
that doesn't make sense
right unless your house kind of fired
that's one scenario
is your house caught on fire
maybe
well there are some like banksy
destroyed a piece of art and then the
only real
version was the nft that's interesting
uh way to approach it but oh no dude
anyway whatever talks about enough about
this [ __ ]
i just don't like how much people like
put this guy on a pedestal as some
genius i think he's a douche
did you find that video maybe
oh thank you olivia yeah here he is
i don't know why this one rubbed me
wrong too it's another like pseudo
inspirational one he posted who works
hard at me are you me
how do you know that you just can't be
working 18 hours a day every day the way
i am
i just don't think you are
i just believe it in my heart you don't
really know anything about me you're
right okay i worked every hour of my 20s
all of them yeah i did too you guys see
how hard i'm working now
think about what i was doing when i
didn't have
douche chills i don't like it i don't
like the like your life is your work
thing either
like especially in this day and age you
know
most people are just wage slaves to
[ __ ] applebees and
you need to have time off like life is
not work
i don't think we're gonna do it i don't
think working 18 hours a day is good i
don't think that's inspirational i think
that's sick that's mental illness you
guys men they're doing impossible things
you know
sort of near you me
where would we be without gary vee he's
working 18 hours a day he's drawing
stick figure worms and selling them for
a hundred thousand dollars
where would we be
without men
do you think a woman could draw a stick
figure worm no work themselves to death
women can't do what men do
women can't scam you with nfts
where would we be without men like
garyvee
he works 18 19 hours a day
he sleeps for three hours
he showers well he drinks his coffee
he takes a tub he takes a tupperware of
water and gives himself a
sponge bath in the morning he doesn't
have enough time to shower
garyvee sleeps in his trunk there's not
enough time
he takes a power nap for 10 minutes at a
time and forces himself to wake up
where would we be without him
where would we be without people like
a.b
he's a man
would you like a b would you like for
your bonus for the year i'll buy you one
of his uh nfts absolutely
really absolutely you don't want the
cash you want a gary vee nft absolutely
without a doubt
you want a question actually that shit's
way too expensive [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that
it's like a hundred thousand dollars
i'm gonna come in here in a pimp suit
after after break after please drop that
[ __ ] i bought it with the uh
when i flipped
maybe
where would we be
so anyway that's your boy
garyvee
making out with his dad selling nfts
working 18 hours a day
speaking of where would we be without
men this one comes to you from alpha
official
how to pick up chicks from a alpha king
let's go we've actually watched this
guy's videos a few times before here
yeah he was the one who was saying men
you need to man spread more
right because it's alpha beta
here he is with the news how are you
doing my name is aaron what's your name
janice janice pleasure today question
janice all right so who around here
makes the best pizza boom everybody
loves pizza everybody oh my god dude
shut the [ __ ] up
i mean
i hate him okay also has an opinion on
who makes the best pizza dominoes no way
i got okay so here's the deal i'm gonna
anyway is that true i don't really i'm
not like and i'm a guy that loves pizza
but i'm not like
that [ __ ]
passionate about who makes the best
pizza
he has no pizza experience yeah this
guy's a frog
take you out this weekend for pizza
saturday what's your number smooth
gentlemen it's time for you to make it
real
how you doing my name is yeah that's not
a real conversation bro i don't know how
smooth what was that
what is it about makes me so uncomfy
about this video what's your name janice
janice pleasure today question janice
all right so who around here makes the
best pizza boom everybody loves people
you know what the problem is it's like
he's trying to sell her an nft or
something
the way he's approaching her all right
janice listen up here we go
i got this nft
i got this pizza nft i'm trying to sell
you what do you think
it's like the guys you all try to shine
my shoes
they don't lay off
your shine box yeah my man my man
my name is aaron what's your name janice
janice pleasure today question hey
i would be like stop yelling at me
please chill bro
is his is his pitch really that you
should go for to asking someone out in
the course of 20 seconds i mean that
doesn't seem natural
he needs me how are you doing my name is
aaron what's your name janice janice
pleasure to be hey question jeff all
right so who around here makes the best
pizza boom everybody loves pizza
everybody also has an opinion on who
makes the best who around here
so it's about something that everyone
has opinion on okay
so hey janice listen uh do you wipe from
the front or back uh
everybody wipes from the everybody wipes
their ass
i love pizza and i love janice did you
know that some people wipe from the
front and some people wipe from the back
boom
it's a great conversation starter
janice listen
uh what's something everyone cares about
oh no
how you doing anyway whatever i guess no
not hidden
jeff bezos
got his girl taken from leo and that was
pretty awesome
yo i gotta say
i this kind of puts in the context why
jeff bezos is on a quest to
[ __ ] the world
because he it got look how his girl
just
she is ready to leave him
she doesn't care how rich how powerful
this man is
she is ready
to never see him again
in the face of leonardo
watch this
look at the way she's looking at him
he's like peace out girl you're giving
me the creeps
yeah she's definitely way too old that
goes without being said i mean how old
is she is his age limit is like she's
51.
51. she's like double his age she's not
even permitted to speak to him yeah
yeah but she's pushed she's
she's putting it on pretty heavy don't
you think
it's like a comic book uh
pining on him
and little cocky bezos over here
um leonardo capital refuses to date
women over the age of 25 i guess nobody
explained this to her
yeah sorry bezos looks really short in
that video i think leo's on a step or
something okay but i do think bezos is
probably a short king okay
he just he looked yeah he looked pretty
sure
you think he's short five seven yeah
he's a short king
and now it's like five seven yeah
leo's gotta be silver six foot right i
don't think leonard
i think he's short too no i think leo is
six foot
yeah okay
yeah well fair enough
who cares you don't care that polly is
yeah
um she does i don't know
if i watched a video of me standing next
to ila to her talking to someone like
this i would feel i would feel pretty
bad i'll be honest she wants she's ready
to leave him
am i wrong
you know i think it's funny to dunk on
jeff bezos because [ __ ] him but to be
honest i i don't know if i really find
this that bad dude
she is ready to [ __ ]
she would eat his dirty [ __ ] she's
she presented it she's got the [ __ ] me
there's no this is like
i'm sorry but she would literally just
[ __ ] take his nuts in her ass right
now
okay
i mean with peace and love olivia what
do you think i think she's being flirty
she's like
from below looking up all like
daddy
verb form to cornhole
yeah i don't know it's it's pretty
embarrassing where she's like
mm-hmm exactly
anal sex
excuse me
i think i've told this story but i had a
girlfriend who wanted me to put my balls
in her butt before you have told that
story it bears repeating
are you guys laughing because i've said
it so many times or just no you i don't
that was a hell of a transition there i
mean
why am i not recalling this oh my god
yeah i had a girlfriend in
college who really wanted me to put my
balls in her butt and i was like i don't
see it happening
i didn't really attempt it either
because i knew it was just gonna be pain
fascinating
crazy
oh no what's in her butthole she want me
to put it in her
vagina
i
good
misremembered
it's still pretty much the same story
yeah yeah it didn't make that much of a
difference well it's more
i could see that more possible than the
other yeah it's more possible you might
correct you're not going the other way
the the butthole would be a harder
i think a heart a more challenging feat
i've already taken my pants off okay
chill jeremy it's just not happening
it's not happening jeremy
yeah and then jeff daddy bezos tweeted
out this photo which i hate okay like i
guess i get it's funny but i don't like
the whole relatable bezos [ __ ] i'm i'm
not into it
he gives me the creeps leah come over
here i want to show you something danger
steep cliff i want you to throw me off
this cliff
i don't like relatable bezos
he's just a down-to-earth guy when he's
not in space he actually could kill
someone and get away with it like easily
oh yeah absolutely
i mean jeff bezos has murdered multiple
people
are you you're saying that like
unironically dan yes
you're
well like epstein because like he would
i mean he
he would definitely i think it's safe to
assume that he's probably had somebody
killed
this what
that's huge i'm just it's not an
accusation it's speculation but but i'm
just gonna go out i'm gonna go out on a
limb and say that jeff bezos has
probably had somebody i'm gonna go out
on a limb and say he's a murderer for
sure yeah but you know what like i get
it though he could make you disappear
right let's see what happens
well within his his uh ability to
and
he seems ruthless enough that he you
know at some point it was probably
beneficial
to you know get the permits moving along
in some third world country where he's
got some activity going on and oh
there's no world yeah just just off the
guy just just get it done you know what
you don't get to be worth 200 billion
without dropping a few uh world heads
i'm not
i'm not making anything
i haven't heard any rumors i i don't
know of any specific instance but
it it's just you know if we were betting
on it
has jess bezos killed a man i i would
definitely bet on yes
that's a good point i i would too if if
there was odds in vegas like has jeff
bezos killed been responsible for
someone right and somehow you know just
some
omnipotent god could just
know for sure and give you a definitive
answer and and i'm betting on that i
would bet yes what would you guys vote
as jeff bezos killed someone i i agree
with dan i can't argue with his
transcended form
anyone else
i feel like
i don't know i would like to believe in
humanity enough to where someone doesn't
call a hit out i think
definitely indirectly like when he was
making his workers work through the
pandemic oh i think
i mean that that i will make a specific
accusation on
that one is definitely true but i'm
talking about ordering the death of
another human i hate that uh he's the
accidental count
do you think phil gay
don't count known like cheney in the
woods i know the guy survived but wait
you think bill gates has killed someone
jeffrey epstein um jeff definitely
that's not even important yeah i mean
yeah warren buffett
warren buffett i really don't know much
about one buffalo
man i i don't know i defend daddy buff
it garyvee
garyvee maybe
maybe i don't i don't
i mean he imagines it
he's got he's got a little bit of idea
yeah with the idea of people of murder
no i don't i don't know no i don't i
don't think garyvee's killed anyone but
i'd say bezos yes and and yeah bill
gates bill gates yeah he's he's ordered
the death elon musk
um
probably
dan's just imaginable every billionaire
is just a mass murderer i said not every
i feel like but but i mean those big
three those are like the three richest
men in the world right
yeah
bill gates and jeff bezos all three of
them yeah i would bet on i feel like i
mean actually out of all three i would
say bill gates the most mm-hmm
you think gates killed ase is a [ __ ]
psycho dude that dude has for sure had
somebody off do you think bill gates has
had sex with kids
it's
within the realm of possibility well
yeah he was buddies with them records
yeah
i don't think he well billy boy
at least he didn't fly on epson's plane
oh right right we looked into that yeah
oh he never did
no but he did have a long association
with him and and the thing is is like
when people always trout out as like oh
they're not on the flight records it's
like bill gates has his own plane
you know what i mean
around he does he doesn't he doesn't
need a ride to the island he can find
his own way
you okay so we have updates about
asteroids segwaying here uh well a
little bit unfortunately
jesus
because we're talking about yeah people
died there oh my god
it's not a good segment inappropriate
but it's the story that's on our list
and um i have to talk about it
yeah so i want to talk about astro world
i want to follow this story
the new
thread on this astro world is that after
the show
we talked about how it was declared a
mass casualty event
the show went on for another 40 minutes
after the show ended travis scott
and drake went to
dave and busters
and and by the way
of all the places to go
dave and buster when i saw that
when i saw reporting about this
i gotta
admit i was skeptical because it just
seemed
so absurd that that's where they would
have an after party like not at like a
club or something it's not like 16 year
olds have birthday parties oh well it
was drake's thing wasn't it
drake is definitely the type of dude to
have an after party at dave and busters
i mean dave and buster's it's fun i like
dave and buster's but it's basically
just an arcade
place
let's play some skee-ball yeah kind of
like going to chuck e cheese after
committing a mess yeah it's like chuck e
cheese for grown-ups no ball it's
chucky's minus the ball pit
unfortunately
it's the best part
yeah and um
i just find it odd like of all the
places to go is this 100 is this story
yeah it's confirmed it's confirmed yeah
it's not [ __ ] it is according to
team because it's just so over there i'm
pretty sure like i was really really
skeptical that this was real
just and also like dave and busters are
usually like this like in
shopping malls
you know sometimes i mean so
there's some standalone dave and
buster's looking but it looks like this
i mean it looks like a chucky cheese you
got a great deal on a pitcher
here this is chucky this is dave and
busters oh they what they do sports
there okay epic yeah i mean yeah it's
definitely for adults there's a bar
there
drinking's encouraged and everything but
yeah i mean it definitely has kind of
like a
is it is chuck e cheese for adults it's
b dubs and chuck e cheese heaven a baby
i wonder okay sure speed that's what the
kids say
that is what we said what the [ __ ] is
b-dubs b-dubs buffalo wild b-dubs yeah i
live you know what i was talking about
i've never even heard of that because i
go to school in ohio
like our restaurant that makes sense
michigan ohio well anyway i wonder how
was the crowd controlled that night uh
were they packed in there were there any
crowd surges at dave and busters
i mean not that i recall
these are pretty popular
yeah super weird
i mean there's no way he couldn't know
if something happened by the end of that
show 40 minutes
and then he gets off stage he leaves
he talks to the the director the
producer everybody there's so much staff
all aware all the place
and nobody tells him and they go to dave
and busters and play arcade games
playing [ __ ] deer hunter and [ __ ] you
know
i don't believe that
i don't believe it do you think he was
like super [ __ ] up or something
like maybe he was so
blasted but he was just unaware
i mean i don't unders no there's no way
that like
in the time from like
concert ends
you step off the stage
no like it was already a story but i
have an idea
hold on i have an idea
where was the um concert and i know i
was in texas where was it houston no but
okay so what was the venue
i don't know that someone someone
figured that out world venue
nrg park play play the the no such thing
as a com uh coincidence okay so it's
called ng park nrg park nrg park houston
okay so
so hang on guys we're gonna figure this
out this is gonna be really illuminating
nrg park
here it is on the map
now what we need to do is find out
where's the closest busters okay
okay
i got this
yeah yeah directions dave director can
you put on astroworld
oh
okay now hold on my result is it's kind
of far okay this is compelling
it's a 25 minute drive
from the venue to the closest
dave and busters
assuming
now is assuming he went to the closest
one it seems like there's another one
here another one there
he could have gone to one of the ones
that's further away
so he had not only the time off of the
stage
but to drive for 25 minutes as the story
broke as people at the venue as his work
associates his agents his managers
everybody his touring manager find out
it seems like a little bit of a stretch
25 minutes somehow was not informed of
anything going wrong he got get park his
car get into dave and buster's order to
drink play a few games of ski ball skeet
ball
i imagine a tour bus but
yeah so it's even slower right
i i don't know if he was on a tour bus
yeah he went it was just a one-shot
thing it wasn't a tour yeah probably had
his own personal vehicle
do you think it was like an escalade or
like a like an extended escalade
extended escalator
maybe suburban do you think it was maybe
like one of those like like a mercedes
suv of some kind like a sprinter van
no that's right
guys guys guys that that's not important
let's find out pictures of the dave and
busters he was at
here it is
he was oh they have bowling alleys at
dave and busters
some of them that's sick
you want to go i kind of do want to go
to david buster's and i i'm not even
responsible for anyone dying without a
party after the first year we should we
should totally do a
party at dave and buster what's up
what's up let's rage david buster's yo
that's kind of like buying i'm just
doing an ad for dave and busters now
that's like pretty good looking food
hey i got a great steak i tell you man
are you [ __ ] kidding me
no what
yeah so this is drake right here
apr sorry that's travis scott eight
people died
yo give me some more tokens give me some
tokens b
he's winning tickets
he's eating sundays
this is a little bit much nobody does
that
blue cheese
take a look at the other screen real
quick
yeah which which one of these do you
think he traveled there in
the right brown one matches his batman
well he was probably traveling with like
um kylie right so probably a two seater
and a baby and his baby oh
yeah for the car seat you're gonna need
an suv so he probably got in the car
he's like that was a rager bro
that was a good ass show
all of his cars are uh brown huh yeah
just like his shoes that he
really loved
it's not like
the worst car color but it's not very
flattering yeah legit
let's go to dave and buster's though
like on the real like right now short of
people don't like wrap this [ __ ] up
where is there dave and buster's nearby
probably yes don't look it up
i already did i'm doing no but i mean
like not on the screen well well we're
not going to be there when they're there
they'll never find us we're not going to
be there when drake and travis scott are
there
they're still at dave and buster's he
actually still doesn't know
he's trying to beat uh he's trying to
beat that x-men game from 1990 he's the
side scroller beat him up yeah yeah
absolutely it's a tough one
yeah so that's i find that pretty
interesting like
their people are just
there's no [ __ ] way that he didn't
know by that
who do you think travis mained
oh probably probably wolverine because
in that game wolverine he's kind of got
the same brown
colored suit as uh his cars
right
there's no such thing as a coincidence
you seen that
you're not looking at the screen either
i'm looking at i don't know what you
want me to say about it
i would guess colossal about the
wolverine
i was just noting yeah yeah he would he
would main wolverine yeah okay thank you
thank you
you can close it
thank you okay
your beanie has
grown like four sizes since we started
the show
cam said something and i was looking at
your beanie
yeah oh you want to do the beanie yeah
you skipped a pretty big topic here oh
here's actually here's a shot of him
after the show at dave and buster's
with a bunch of 12 year olds in his
batman oh
that was nice of him to to do that he
did a quick make-a-wish yeah exactly
actually you know what's interesting the
last time that but there was um two
make-a-wish kids who wanted to meet me
oh and you went to david we met him at
dave and buster that's right great kids
by the way great dudes shout they're
awesome dudes
all right what do you want to do you
want to you want to look at the weird
beanie hair
fake hairline king i mean sure let's
open it i mean we need an answer this
was all over reddit there was a bunch of
posts about this yeah 24 points i see
it's really uh
talk of the town
look how many awards though this
specific one
how many awards it has zero oh wait i
was looking at the video with it
literally
all right so here
what the [ __ ] was that really
i mean it's obviously just my hair
like here okay you see my hair hairline
k what do you want you want to get come
get the close-up i could probably
replicate it i mean it it
i agree it was of kind of a weird fluke
where my hair bunched up in a weird way
let me see
because there's kind of like
you see
or was it maybe it was on this side
i think it was being pulled i mean up to
the left your left i honestly have no
idea what was going on it looks really
bizarre for sure it really does but
do a close-up of me okay so i think i've
done it
hold on if the beanie pulls the other
part back
i mean that's pretty close right
yeah i mean it's a little close yeah
just at one side we legit cannot see no
hair
yeah that's the thing is it's still air
hang on
yeah it's just they had that perfect
line yeah i mean it's close but you can
hopefully you can believe me a little
bit that that this is all that happened
i believe you okay thank you believe
your hair is real well here let me see
if i'm wearing a toupee hold on
come close up on me so i want to try to
pull my hair
oh my god okay all right we believe you
we believe you no i want to prove it
cam sent a bunch of the threads
there's like five or six here a lot of
conversation about my hairline
exposed um here let's take a look
we have one two three four five
uh that's five these are all older so
five threads let's see uh the one with
the most has five comments let's see
what the conversation is six up votes
well this is just with the keyword
hairline
true i think you're trying to cover this
up
how am i covering up i'm expo i'm i'm
confronting it in the most direct way
possible
what am i covering up ask me any
question
go ahead a b what the [ __ ] was going on
in that phone
i mean there is a weird
way
as fun as it would have been to expose
you i i think you've
i think you've debunked
the uh raging rumors it would be kind of
amazing if i had an actual hair like
hair system toupee yeah it was so crazy
i'm just totally involved in quite a
revelation
all right you should shave your head
and then get one and see if anybody
notices
interesting
we need to talk about the main story
because they're probably almost out of
time eh
uh yeah
wait we talked about astroworld we
talked about
oh [ __ ]
we didn't do the bizarre roommate
stories we don't have time for that do
we um
know how much time we have left
about 15 minutes
bit redemption auction was cancelled
this is real interesting we've been
following this story with carlos
speaking of nfts yeah
okay wait we have an offer of 230 what
happened here let's see
oh did they remint it two days ago what
happened here uh love you've been
following this it keeps going now so
oh i see yeah bid
cancelled oh so they never sold it for
the 200 yeah
so they bailed
yeah
they bought bed last second yeah so they
had that one up for auction
for and the highest bid was about you
know
i mean 200 bucks there's nothing to
scoff at no the highest bid back then
was 80 bucks or 60 okay 80 bucks sure i
mean that's more than i thought it would
go for yeah that bid came in after after
the castle
um so is there no more auction is this
just dead and like this whole thing it's
just done
seems like it yeah oh man
no now's your chance carlos this was
your big redemption bro i think i'm
putting it on the crypto bros i i think
carlos would have followed through
you think they asked a lawyer and then
he's like do not sell that
they're like oh [ __ ]
this is so crazy to me
i guess now it's just having a big joke
out of it
well didn't you say they spent three
thousand bucks minting this and then now
it's all off or not yeah more than 3k
are you sure that they cancelled it all
together
yeah
you can see well nothing's for auction
right now
right
they i think they've just bailed on this
project i see so you can make an offer
but you can't but that doesn't
necessarily mean it's well they have to
accept it this one has the highest offer
point three which is one thousand four
hundred dollars i don't know why i feel
like you should be taking it take that
offer well the problem is is that it's
probably his friend who's making the
offer
uh
i kind of look through that their
stuff uh on the beach shade or
yeah i didn't find any connections
anyways
so you think that's a legit offer
yeah this is
that's probably the best one
you know what would have been genius if
they got carlos
to draw what basically the most
rudimentary
version of a worm
right that would have sold for a hundred
thousand they [ __ ] up yeah
i would have bought it
why did the same person offer the same
amount three times what does that mean
maybe because they wouldn't accept it
they rejected it you think or they're
struggling to use this website because
it's awful
and accidentally put three bids in
this seems like an experience to eat
user
okay whatever well shout out to carlos
hope you make it buddy we're all rooting
for you to become a millionaire at least
break even on all the minting
i hope you know
barbara ripping off someone's beard
i've been seeing a lot of this on tick
tock on instagram what i just can't say
that i see the value the
the advantage to waxing facial hair off
as opposed to just shaving this really
blew me away
you can see the whole thing just
shifting it's all just attached
this is not going to be
[ __ ] terrific
just shave i mean guys
the razor is great
it's been around
for a long time now
he looks like he's about to cry
this is such a bad idea
this is straight guantanamo bay torture
might as well waterboard him
oh my god
oh my god
what did he do what did this guy do to
you to put him through this
guys you're a barber use a [ __ ] razor
look how his skin is all tore out and by
the way it's lots of hair and wax
remaining
and they've got two guys pulling this
wax off his face he's bleeding he still
has hair on his face
this may be
the worst barber
of all time and now we're watching boss
baby for some reason
oh my god [ __ ] off
this is just pain
oh my god you guys
and now it's just stuck on his goatee
which you know is gonna be bad bad bad
look at his lip the poor man
yeah no man this is the best oh [ __ ] he
still has hair on his face he looked
great dude
he looks [ __ ] great
what a fresh new cut look at this final
clip before and after
what a novel technique they've got there
i think they're really onto something
sign me up let's get this thing off so
he's still got hair all over his face
he's bleeding
he still has hair there too
man
oh that is brutal
i want to hear let's do it before and
after
okay you know what tick tock
i swear to god
he looks kind of good with the black
ones just leave it on yeah
it's a look
it's a vibe that was a really good one
shout out to that barber
i'm sure they're gonna have lots of
business coming in for that
well could i convince one of you guys to
do that [ __ ] no
jesus ian would do anything for money
apparently right ian
the beard that's next level yeah that
whole beard wax that beard up let's go
waxing hurts but it's not like
that crazy
mm-hmm
it's like it's painful but
have you had your face
have you had your face waxed like that
have
with like a huge amount of like
you don't have a beard yeah i i don't
know
it's a whole different level i will say
i think waxing
like lady hair
on the leg and arm or even matt man hair
is different than like be long beard
hair right it would be like waxing the
hair off the top of your head
essentially like that would that would
be horrific right but like what about
when girls waxed their bikini line
well i'm sure that it hurts a lot i bet
it does i i'm sure it does
i don't know the skit well i mean the
bikini line sure that's very sensitive
too but like the skin on your lip and
stuff with like a huge amount of hair
being ripped out i think yeah maybe it
all just really hurts yeah maybe it just
all hurts how about that well ab said
you do it you volunteer to do that let
me see your facial hair let me see a
close-up would you would you do it with
your hair like that long
because i think that's what they did if
i could cover my face for like a week
yeah bro
i don't know you don't have a lot but
that
that would still hurt i had a horror
story once i don't know if this is just
like a middle eastern type of wax but
have you ever heard like a ball wax
olivia like girls like they like sugar
so it's called you're talking about oh i
don't know it's called right
i had an x that was using it and she
thought it was funny to just throw the
ball the wad on my ass
and it was the most pain i think i've
ever been in it's like this
uh sort of but yeah yeah it looks like
that but it's like like you can roll in
a complete ball yeah that's sugaring
gotcha
well i don't think i would do that to
you ab i think that would be really
really horrible not funny just horrible
pain
yeah and the other crazy thing that we
learned that i wanted to talk about
was this height lengthening surgery
super interesting and i don't know
um apparently you can increase your
height
okay
um yeah i've heard of this
this girl increased her height three
inches i just don't think that three
inches is worth it because
what they do is so traumatic on the body
and you cannot walk for a year
jesus did you know you can permanently
get 12. okay chill dude if you're going
to be doing
height increasing surgery you've got to
make better videos everybody's dr
mabubian i wanted to explain to you guys
a little bit about what the height
lengthening procedure is i make small
little tiny incisions around your legs
and on your hips and then we put this
nail which is called the precise nail
now this is a self-lengthening nail
however it is controlled with a magnet
once it's inserted inside the leg and a
small tear your bones apart this nail
slowly lengthens over time separating
out the bone and neutral bone
is actually stronger than your regular
bone and over time this bone will harden
and become a permanent part of your body
so that's the high lengthening procedure
in the nutshell hope you guys enjoyed it
that has got to feel
horrible wow yeah well here i have some
interesting before and afters this is
this guy's whole niche yeah it turns out
we looked into him and he's actually not
even an md
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
he would be though someone like this
he's like the doctor from the simpsons
hey everybody i'm dr nick i heard you
want it to be three inches taller
um here this is the one yeah so this guy
here he increased his height from five
three
to five six
i don't know i mean i guess i i don't
know what it's like to have that kind of
insecurity
but it's just it's only three inches
like he's still short
i mean he's still a short king
i hope he doesn't see this i mean five
six is still short and he just couldn't
walk for a year
oh he does look more confident though on
the second pick
uh sure look how the doctor towers over
him he looks even he [ __ ] him dude the
doctor looks even taller in the second
picture the doctor also had the
procedure
like seriously it's an arms race he
looks taller than him
all these uh short guys that are
insecure about it they're gonna get this
procedure but then all the tall guys are
also gonna get it and so proportionally
they'll still be
as short as they were before it's very
sad apparently you can do a double one
where you can grow six inches which is
actually pretty insane
six inches yeah that cannot be healthy
it takes about three to four months of
assistive walking which means that you
use a walker when you're getting how his
legs his legs are not walking
they're like opening from the side it
takes about six months before you're
walking normal without any
assistance about eight months before
you're running and about a year before
you're back to sports
did you know
and then it takes about a year and six
months before your leg fractures
completely in half and you'll be
immobilized for life
but at least you'll be able to tell
people you're 5'6
although you'll be about 4 2 in the
wheelchair you can permanently get
taller 11.
god there was a south park episode where
they did this and kyle wanted to play
basketball and he goes and plays
basketball and he blows his knees out
like he loses his legs
so i wonder if something like that would
happen
i think so for sure i think this was
wide enough don surgery
uh people's would just be busting apart
for sure here's another short king he
went from five three to five eight so
this guy got
dude that's crazy he got
five inches that's pretty significant
you know
yeah very much so here's a
transformation of a young man in his
third everything
yeah he was 5'3 he was a tiny little
dwarf he hated himself and i spit on him
when he came in the office i feel that's
crazy he wrote that
he said he put that in his caption
that's [ __ ] he says there's nothing
worse than being short i literally
kicked him in the balls and called him a
tiny [ __ ] yeah i was like whoa
chill dude he underwent the height
lengthening procedure on his femur and
his tibias yeah so he did both
in a staged fashion using the
uh stride nail he gained a grand total
of 5.8 inches almost six and his height
he nan stands at five nine he's still a
short piece of [ __ ] but he's not as bad
as he used to be that's so weird the
demeanor is yeah why does he talk that
way
why am i still getting hate
yeah i don't know man
i think there's a reason people don't do
this procedure that much
they do look more confident though
you know
but a year recovery for that [ __ ] i
don't know
oh let's see what i mean
i'm sure it is safe like it does seem to
be a i'm not sure
sanctioned
uh accepted
prod
well i mean all of surgeries have an
inherent risk but like as far as like an
elective
service you think it's sanctioned do you
have any uh literature on that i'm
pretty sure this is pretty
strange business
this man underwent the height
lengthening procedure on his femur a few
months ago he was five six
now he's five nine wanted to show you
what his scars look like yeah not bad
honestly actually
really not bad at all
that's amazing they just straight up add
this much but wouldn't it wouldn't that
mean like his legs are
disproportionately
like freakishly long compared to the
rest of his body
don't people like that anyway long long
legs daddy long legs
maybe
i mean it doesn't look that weird to me
looking at him here did you know you can
permanently get taller six if you have
bell legs knock knees
we can correct your lower limb deformity
during the height lengthening procedure
insurance might cover some of the cost
oh my insurance ain't covering that
yeah i'm not going to do that hey kaiser
i need a million dollar height uh
i need a million dollar height
increasement surgery you guys do that
did you know it's super expensive too
how much is the cost it said
on this website
seen eighty thousand hundred thousand
and up whoo
at least it's expensive you know that at
least he's probably knows what he's
doing if it was like five thousand i'd
be worried yeah permanently oh wait i
wanna see these deformities they fix
yeah those [ __ ]
why are you laughing at somebody's
deformity
because i feel like he causes this you
don't fix it i saw the dude come out of
there his knees were hella far apart uh
knees or a limb length discrepancy we
can't correct your lower i like the
music too it's like yeah the music and
the [ __ ] obnoxious tick-tock voice
it's like this doesn't seem very you can
invest a little more in your marketing
i've known someone with knockouts and
they've described it as very painful and
as they got older it was a lot worse oh
i'm so sorry we well this guy can fix
him and make him taller all at once
yeah i'll get this guy's number was he
tall or was he king like five ten
he could be over six feet with this
man's help
i don't think they're supposed to do it
on people that are already yeah of
average height or taller
from what i'm from what i'm uh that
means if i'm if that means if i'm five
eleven i can add six inches bro i would
be six four i would tower over you you
get a giga ethan dude i would i could be
six four with this zach
isn't he no i would be six five six
three i would be six five i'll tower
over you zack
well zach do it too and then [ __ ] dunk
on your ass zach you could be like seven
feet tall dude you you'd be hassan size
yeah yeah yeah
that would be so cool
it makes zach look short yeah
i've never seen zach look short around
anyone my brother makes me look short
well hassan's just a unit all together
it's just a moving
all right um we have to end the show we
are out of time
i was just getting started with the leg
[ __ ] one week ago this man underwent
cosmetic limb lengthening to get three
inches taller we have one of my
co-starving lengthening patients he did
his femurs about a week ago he said that
he's doing really can you not use that
music
oh yeah
yeah
he's being very careful not to put too
much weight on his legs and using a
walker when he's walking around so these
are his incisions everything's very
small tiny incisions this is where we're
really
from
and these two incisions are where we cut
the bone and there's another
uh incision up at the top we insert the
nail so can you straighten out your legs
for us
that's great and bend it as far as it
goes
it's scary this [ __ ] just scares you
we're gonna breathe be careful not to
you have to use a walker you could
literally snap both of your legs in half
that's horrible
face out of that shot
he's probably in tears oh yeah
definitely
and start getting them taller
one week wow yeah like an interesting
shit's coming up i'm still i'm still
waiting for the penis heightening
surgery thank you well they have that
they have that no way yeah their penile
reduction and reduction yeah that's the
thing
penis reduction surgery you have penile
reduction nobody's ever gotten that
jason nash had uh penile enlargement
jason nash got his penis enlarged
what
you want to whisper like had him do that
no no don't you yeah that's [ __ ] good
no it's true trisha had jason get it i
think it's still it's still totally
online he willingly did it he had like
multiple sessions yeah
imagine that your girl's like your dick
is too small i need you to enlarge it
wait didn't she tell me what she likes
small penises i think it was more that
she wanted i don't know if we're allowed
to talk about this say it say i think
it's more that she wanted to have sex
like multiple times a day and that was
helpful with that as well as making it
he couldn't perform it makes it even
hotter i know i think she just
i rem never mind what i want everything
no keep talking no i'm sorry my screen
popped oh yes
what the [ __ ] are you looking at
penile enlargement i think she talked
about how like she wanted to have sex
like five times a day and he was like i
just can't do that
was that a stamina thing yeah how's that
a penis enlargement thing i think the
because the way it worked it was like a
huge suction
thing yeah so the way that i've heard is
that you pump you have to pump it up and
that is not the penis enlargement
surgery i'm looking for oh you want like
the bone to be split in half with the
rod just like i want a nail that self
grows no but like you have to literally
pump your [ __ ] up and that's pretty
narrow you want it to use a walker for
six days a penis walker
dude some of these pictures i'm saying
it looks like you'll need a walker but
something's like a transplant it's not
what you think right you have to pump it
up
i'm looking for it's not like a natural
penis situation yeah they make
mechanical
[ __ ] but you know
i think there's one procedure that tell
me about the penis uh
uh
when you make it smaller every site that
has any information about this is just
it's just porn it's just like a massive
amount of porn popping up so okay cam
sent me something interesting here oh my
god yo this is gonna be me but after my
after my six inch enlargement surgery
dude this could be me you guys it looks
so natural and hot
[ __ ] you're not as [ __ ] i'm gonna
look so hot all tall
oh that's awesome that's so awesome
all right we are out of time we've been
all right
we'll come back next week with more
intel on the penis uh reduction surgery
absolutely
he has a massive penis
thank you yeah all right well thanks for
watching everybody this has been off the
rails it's been a little bit of
definitely been off the rails today i
don't know what the [ __ ] the show was
just
probably hopefully we got a good
clickbait title though just to rope you
guys in
right
yeah sure
thank you everyone we'll see you on
friday
you